we just heard from Oliver Dowden talking
about the government's policy on Rwanda
he said he doesn't relish any of it but
the government is being forced to do it
because of the increasing number of
small boats crossing the channel is that
fair enough
well forced to do what everyone accepts
that this is a major problem it's a
crisis we've got record number of boats
arriving on the coast criminal gangs
profiting and an asylum system in chaos
but the question is what is the
government actually doing so far they've
done several PR opportunities and photo
ops we've had 140 million pounds of
checks written to Rwanda in order to
implement a scheme that hasn't removed a
single person this is just more stunts
from this government what they should be
doing is what Labor's been calling for
for a very long time take the money that
is being spent on this unethical
unworkable scheme and put it into the
National Crime agency to create a
cross-border cell in order to disrupt
the criminal gangs who are profiting
from people's misery that will be the
best way to stop the small boats and
back it up with proper resources at the
front end of the Asylum system so that
we can process cases swiftly and get a
great on what has become an unwieldy
system that is completely out of control
you know what that would be the best
thing to do if we're living in a perfect
world but the fact is we're really not
if it was that easy to stop the
smuggling gowns you'd see other
countries in the world doing it you know
Interpol themselves or saying how
difficult it is they're not like usual
unorganized crime because of the
transient nature of their relationships
with their victims you know burn of
phones they often don't know their real
names you know labor could say that it
wants to wave a magic wand and just
smash the smuggling gangs but that's not
a serious solution
I don't think that diverting resources
into setting up a specialist National
Crime agency cell is waving a magic wand
what it's doing is the hard yards that
this government hasn't been prepared to
do to tackle what is a very challenging
criminal problem that is exploiting some
of the most desperate people in the
world people who will are fleeing War
who are fleeing persecution are
relieving such desperate circumstances
that unless we do roll up our sleeves
and do the hard yards to deal with the
problem at source the conditions that
they're fleeing to deal with an asylum
system that leaves people languishing
for months and often years waiting for a
decision to deal with criminal gangs who
have ruthlessly exploited the fact that
this government has refused to get a
grip on the problem has refused to work
constructively with other countries in
order to do so unless we do that we're
going to see what we've seen for the
last decade which is this problem
continue to get worse and worse the bill
is going up the waiting times are going
up the number of boats are going up
since the Prime Minister said he was
going to get a grip on this and
legislate to stop it last year we've
seen the number of Boat Crossings reach
record highs 45
000 last year the government continues
to make promises big talk and photo
opportunities but what we're calling for
is precisely the action that you talked
about Sophie not a magic wand not a
silver bullet but real work to to tackle
these gangs to tackle this problem and
to make sure that where we do offer
people Sanctuary we can do so swiftly
and humanely and restore Britain's
reputation in the world again
I also put some of sweller brotherman's
language to Oliver Dowden saying that
it's the kind of language that Gary
lineker likened to that used in 1930s
Germany he said that that was an
appalling comparison by the match of the
day presenter is it
well look I think what people say Gary
lineker said is very different from what
Gary lineker actually said the
government has been Keen to say that he
was likening this to the Nazis that he
wasn't and I would have utterly
condemned that had he done so I don't
think he would have done so frankly what
he was pointing to was a chilling
comparison uh with an environment in
which people aren't free to be able to
challenge this sort of language and
behavior don't forget it was Sue Ella
bravaman who used really inhumane
language about the migrant crisis which
was roundly condemned not just by people
outside of politics but by people across
the political Spectrum including some of
her own colleagues all of this comes
back to the same problem that the
government's policies their answers and
solutions their language is getting
increasingly more outlandish because
they're not prepared to do the work to
actually disrupt the criminal gangs to
speed up the Asylum process and to work
with other countries to deal with the
problems that refugees are fleeing which
is creating instability around the world
now Rishi sunak came to office saying
that he was going to start focusing down
on cleaning up some of his own mess this
is one area where we need far less
posturing far less dangerous talk and
far more real action to deal with what
has been a real problem and labor has
been saying so for a very long time
I want to talk to you about brexit
because of course there will be the vote
next week on The Windsor framework
Oliver dad and says he's confident that
will pass not least of course because
labor is expected to back it do you
think it's a good deal for Northern
Ireland
look I think it's it's a step forward
and we will support a step forward as I
said a moment ago Rishi sunak is
prepared to go and start cleaning up
some of his own mess we're certainly not
going to criticize him for that and
there's no question that this is
something that is now urgent it's
incredibly important and trying to
remove some of that friction some of
those barriers on the island of Ireland
has long been our priority we think the
government ought to get on with it we
hope that vote passes and we hope that
Britain can now start to look to the
Future after 13 long years of drift and
decay under this Tory government this
was budget week this should have been
the moment where Britain got onto the
front foot and started leading the world
not leaving it started winning the race
for good jobs to get money back into
people's pockets started prioritizing
most people in most parts of the country
not just a handful of the wealthiest in
a few parts of the country and instead
here we still are talking about the Tory
failures of the past and how we're going
to fix them we just think Britain could
do so much better than this
talking about how you think Britain
should do better
um you of course are the shadow leveling
not the secretary you want to see more
devolution
now that sounds great of course giving
more power to local communities across
the country but I just wonder in
practice
you know if you look at what is
happening in local authorities in
councils cordon's gone bust woking
Slough thoric Warrington just a few in
financial difficulties you know anyone
who's had any dealings with their actual
local Council might be thinking hang on
you want them to do more
well actually the pandemic paints a very
different story when the national system
just couldn't respond the government
reluctantly handed over the right to run
test trace and isolate systems and other
wrote the role out of the vaccine to
local authorities to Public Health
directors and to communities and we
responded we stepped forward and ran
effective systems in every part of the
country including greater Manchester
where I'm sitting now when the national
system just simply couldn't do it
because we know our own communities we
know the assets and the potential that
exists in those communities not just the
problems that Whitehall is Keen to focus
on and we were able to mobilize people
in order to get the vaccine rolled out
in record time and to get test trace and
isolate up and running 13 years of Tory
government has meant that councils are
reeling they've had 15 billion cut from
their budgets over that time and in this
budget buried in the detail of this
budget was a six billion pound council
tax bombshell actually the government is
forcing councils to put up council tax
in order to fund the services that
currently exist because the national
government has stepped out of the
picture but we believe that this country
could do far far better if we actually
trusted our local businesses and our
local communities to take charge of
their own destiny the government says
that they're in favor of doing that but
in this week's budget which should have
been a game changer they introduced
Evolution deals that cover just nine
percent of the population what about the
missing 90 percent of us we deserve far
better than to be treated by this
government as second-class Citizens on a
second class track to be able to
unshackle ourselves from 13 years of
Tory failure and start to grow our
economies and get money back into
people's pockets again
thank you very much indeed Lisa nandy
there speaking to us thank you